i'm here to start war with these people
because these because
at the end of the day these people were
the people that had killed my my brother
right
these people were the ones that had
gunned down my brother in front of his
family so i had a lot of hate towards
them
i started getting involved with this
from from 20 people i started
i started controlling over the over more
than 150 people
you know that's how strong my unit was
and and compared to the whole cartel
the cartel were working for probably
more than 50 000 stronger man
these guys are no joke like when they
had meetings you would see 200 300
trucks
filled with with military tactical
people like they ain't playing around
with a little with a little handgun they
playing like
you're going to carry yourself you're
going to carry yourself you're going to
carry yourself at least with
five mags six max eight max ready to
fight you know you're ready to die there
because you yeah that's why that's why
you're there it's like
you're very emotional because it's very
powerful brother like
imagine like not nobody came to nobody
came to give me darwin
i had no clue about about islam
everything i knew about islam is what
the west shows you you know
they took down the the the twin towers
and that they're a bunch of terrorists
that they think different but in reality
i didn't know where this found was
um when i asked for this you know i i i
controlled myself and i said i'm not
going to kill myself today
i do the road and i went back to bed
i remember before going to bed man i i
clicked on my own clicked on youtube and
i was looking for something to hear you
know something just to relax
and i don't know where the pro i saw a
uh
recitation from the quran and i i looked
at it and i was like
and you know those black screens where
it's just the quran it's recitating the
crime but no
no nothing on nothing on the screen and
i was like
i'm gonna see what this is and i clicked
on it
really like i can't
share with you what happened my heart
just started one like
it was breaking bro like breaking and i
was crying i wouldn't know why
i didn't know why i was crying like i
was i was crying because of the
recitation i didn't know what it meant
but i was crying you know like i'll be
like
what am i listening to is my life not
testimony enough
to tell you that there's a creator bro
that there's a purpose for you still
standing here
is this not enough to show you that
there's a creator man like you knew i
was gonna die
uh to get
you from this ladies and gentlemen is
the power of shaytan
bro he was getting deep into it too he's
typing
oh he is okay he wrote it's crazy bro
this never happens
damn still typing i told you bro he
wrote that it never happened in my life
it only happened this one other time
when i was speaking to eddie
bro and it's crazy man because it's it's
not
the lag when i was on the d show brother
this same thing happened bro
this never happens to me here i pay for
a high speed internet
and if you heard at the end of the at
the end of the day show like
my my communication got really bad you
know
he's mad bro he's mad and i've been
going through some hard times but
believe me like
it's not easy it's not easy especially
being alone but
i come to you i lost the greatest my
brother and i know that we're not
we're not in the wrong we're not on the
rock path bro when i was fairly starting
to become a muslim right
and i connected my photos to his to his
radio and i started
i started blasting some some sooner i
was rather like
and he was like he looked
oh no
bro two times
uh have you all been hearing
it i i hear like someone going like
that white noise is that white noise or
[Music]
[Music]
what
[Music]
welcome back to the realest podcast in
the dunya the three muslims
we're joined here with our brother zach
gonzalez salaam alaikum
yeah before we begin bro a lot of people
might be wondering
what is your revert story so without
further ado tell us anything we want to
know
well it's a long story but to make it
short you know
grew up in california i was
raised in a christian home right um
but it never went they never went with
me you know i would always ask questions
while i was at church like
why do you guys worship a human being
you know that never
never clicked with me uh something
really hard happened in my family when i
was young you know
um it completely destroyed the family i
had
my father committed something that that
was very horrible in our family and
destroyed it completely you know
i lost uh all faith in in god because
like i would see my mom
striving to become a better christian
and to see that happen to my family
i was 13 years when that happened you
know 13 12 years
and it completely just
erased god out of my life you know i was
like
in a sort of way i was mad at him uh
without knowing who was that right um
mad at that christianity because
my mom and and my whole family was
christians we were raised as christians
uh
and to see that happen in my life you
know it really it was
something really strong my dad ended up
doing uh
16 years in avenue state prison i
haven't seen him since you know
[Music]
but it basically tore us apart and
instead of me
uh keep keep uh instead of me going to
church or
trying to get close to that i started
blaming what happened with my father
with what had happened to my family in
order to
to do things that i was supposed to do
you know i started hanging around with
the wrong crowd
um i remember i started uh
verbally you know starting blood
burgundy because i would see my mom
going through hard times you know
it's it's hard for for a mexican mother
with four kids
uh not knowing english and and having to
work out of out of the blue you know
because because my father wasn't there
anymore
and i would see my mom you know go go
through her times but at the same time
she was like you know what
she would see what i was doing you know
she would see that i would come
sometimes with but money
i was hustling in the streets with the
wrong people doing doing wrong things um
she told me she's like you can't be here
if you're going to be if you're going to
be giving the
bad example to you to your uh to your
brothers i'm the oldest one
uh today i'm turning 29 today on 2029
it's been a long it's been a long
journey since then you know ever since
then
i i've completely like kept kept away
from my family
i've been i haven't seen my mom since
the age of 14 but
that's the last time i've seen my mother
that's the last time that's the last
time i've seen my
my family for hanging around with the
wrong people you know i got involved
with
with dangerous gangs and and it was
basically like
it you know how gangs are right it's
something it's something that it's
there's no end to it you know they kill
one of your mates and you will kill one
of their mates and it goes back and
forth
at the same time i wanted to get away
from all that life you know it's like
i'm gonna go to mexico you know i had
never been in mexico i had grown up all
my life in cali
uh came down to mexico um life
life is hard here you know it's a third
world country it's it's not a
it's not like the u.s you know i i had
no idea what
what mexico was like until i started
living here
um basically i got i got caught up with
some stuff
down here because uh
because of a friend of mine that got
gunned down right
um i started getting involved with with
cartels uh
at a very young age uh by the age of 20
21 i was already rolling rolling with
these cartels i've
like i've said i've i meant work for one
cartel that worked for several cartels
but i started losing that fear you know
that that fear uh that a human has
towards another human it wasn't because
i didn't have fear of god you know i
didn't i didn't really believe that
there was there was a god there was a
higher being
that was in control of everything uh i
was blaming what had happened to my
family when i was young and i was
blaming christianity
for the way that i had i had acted at
the end i know that i'm um
responsible for my count for my actions
you know we're responsible for
our actions and that's it we can't blame
anybody else but
getting involved with this life um it
was crazy man like
it's like i thought that gangs were
violent i had no idea what cartels were
capable of you know the things that they
do
is they're unimaginable and seeing those
things happening to your friends
i have to see close friends you know get
dismembered you know it's it's crazy bro
it's like
there's no like i don't know how to say
how much
how much mexico meets islam you know
islam is
answering and to see that that mexico is
so involved with with uh
with gene activity you know the third is
it's trash bro it's it's something that
it's hard to explain how like in in
words how mexico is
but i was part of that cancer you know
because at the end of the day we're
cancer
cartels are hard that's plain and simple
they're cancer bro they're poisoning
uh young minds because nowadays the kids
they look up to cartel members they look
up to
see guidance you know they say we want
to be like them when we grow up
and you go to to several states in
mexico and
everybody everybody's involved in the
cartels if you're not if you're not
passing information for the cartels uh
if you're not
working as a as a we call them uh
punteros
basically they have radios and they're
stationed in certain points of the city
and and they're reporting to the because
they have their own network
they have their own network they have
their own radios they know when the
government comes they know when the
government leaves
so you're always informed of where the
government is um
and they're like everybody's everybody's
involved you know
i started growing in these cartels
because of of
how how my mentality was you know
like as i said i've always considered
myself a warrior uh
i was really into my my culture you know
that aztec culture
uh there's several revolutionary uh
generals that have passed away here in
mexico but that
that i had a lot of admiration towards
them you know because of
what they did against the government for
the people and
i was always like i was always looking
up to them without
without knowing that i was causing i was
causing a big harm you know um
i get caught up with with all this with
with all this uh situation and i end up
going to uh prison um it was a crazy
story bro like
i got caught up with some weapons and um
the
the government here changed the change
the carpet like
they they changed my crime from weapons
to to murder
uh murder and first degree um
and i did not know if i was going to
leave every prison you know
you're going to prison down here in
mexico and it's for murder
it's 20 to 35 years of prison and you
ain't never going to come out and
especially if you're in the cartels
don't make sure that you don't come out
you know they'll they'll work on your
case to
to to to make sure that you won't leave
prison
um the way that i got i got set up in
prison was that
they took a person that i didn't even
know they made him give a declaration
the testimony that he had saw me uh that
he had saw me kill another person
at the end like this is the murder case
that i had this person had about
dismembered so it was very
like for that type of crime they were
going to give me most likely the most
the most high i was going to be like 35.
um
i i didn't really like i didn't really
understand what i was going like i knew
why i was there you know
of what i had done but going into prison
like
it really changed me you know because
you don't really you don't
really you don't really know who you are
until you're in the very lowest of the
lowest you know
and inside of prison it was crazy um
i started seeing a lot of uh how do you
say shirk
inside of prison like that's what
basically runs the prisons inside
uh they believe in the holy death in
different type of saints
um and they have like you're sleeping
you're sleeping in a cell with six
inmates and each inmate has their own
their own altar with with their candles
and they're saying bro
so you get those vibes you know and i
would get those vibes inside because
i wasn't really a believer but before i
went into prison um
i had i had gone to i had one
i had gone to a party to to to get
someone right
they had give they had given us a heads
up to go go get someone
uh this this this person came up to me
and said i want to tell you something
wrong like
i don't even know you're like why he's
like it's it's just like
i'm a fortune teller like i can see the
future in people
you're crazy man like what are you
talking about um
this person told me that i was gonna in
in four months i was like that something
really bad was gonna happen i was gonna
i was gonna end up getting killed right
um and i didn't believe him at the
moment you know
and he tells me the second thing he's
like i met this
this kid he's in prison right now before
i went into prison he said i met this
kid
i met this kid and his girlfriend and i
told him the same thing that he was
going to end up in prison
and that his girlfriend was going to end
up in a very dark place
a week later this this kid high on drugs
he
he killed his girlfriend and he tried to
hide her in a
wooden box i met this i met this kid
inside of prison right
um and and i i got to live and i got to
live in his cell
talking to him i was like hey i want to
ask you a quick question because like
this is bothering me
are you the did you meet this person
that came up to you a week a week
a week later and did he tell you this
and this is this and
he he said he hadn't sat down bro
because he was like he was shocked right
he he had a goosebumps and he's like you
know i've never told anybody this
this this is scary like how do you know
this and i i
told him and he was like
just be careful because like what this
guy says is it's true
um i didn't understand before you know
why i ended up in prison
now i understand that a lot of time from
you know i was going to get guided to
something that was true
and he was just he was just protecting
me from from from where the gym was
taking me to
because at the end of the day that's
what you're working for you're working
for for people that have
contracts or are dealing with these
powerful gins to destroy uh
the society because that's what you're
doing you're destroying society
you're not fighting for no good reason
there's cartels that say oh we're here
to end with
what other cartels are doing that are
doing uh
worse things you know at the end they're
fighting to do they're they're fighting
to have permission to do what the other
cartels do
that's it and they'll they'll come with
a different flag
but they're all the same color so
when when i when i at the time i didn't
understand why i was there you know
and how did how did that affect me um
i ended up being getting a couple rides
some major rides inside
um i got transferred to a maximum
security prison
uh inside that maximum security prison i
got involved into
uh more uh prison rides uh
really crazy rides man where the same
government the ceos that take care of
the people inside
they got kidnapped by the by the inmates
and they asked for ransom
it was all on the news there's pictures
of the cops laying on the ground
you know being suppressed by the inmates
you know and it's like there's
there's no control in in in the mexican
government you know
it's crazy man but
seeing all that like i still didn't
understand that there was something
better for me
i was thinking that oh i'm gonna i'm
just gonna get reputation in here and
go because like the people that i have
got it i got into i had gotten into
these uh
these big riots were rival cartels that
were impressing the the
the society inside the inmates inside so
they would they would extortion
and then there
they paid the government they paid the
authorities there to do whatever they
want
um so these people were like i was they
were expecting me to get out of prison
and if i did get out there
they wanted to kill me inside of prison
um when i went to maximum security
i started getting connections with hired
people you know people that were
in bigger cartels and they started
seeing that a lot of people followed me
because of the same reason
but because of the reason how i thought
you know i
i would be i would be that type of
person that i'm gonna die fighting you
know i ain't no coward i'm not gonna
i'm not gonna let nobody push me around
and nobody step on me you know
we're we're here because we we've done
we've done things that
no other human being wants to do but at
the end we're here you know
uh but i did not know that that well
allah is all merciful you know
that's why like when i talk about this
like people don't understand that
that the where he took me out of his bro
it's
it it breaks my heart just to understand
like how mercy how merciful
he is to to driving me to the point i am
right now
when i got out of the prison it's
incredible because everyone
everyone that had a wit a protected
witness that was testifying against him
even if they didn't commit the crime
just because the government wanted you
to stay
in prison everyone is still there bro
i'm the only person that was able to
leave prison with winning my case you
know
out of allah's mercy the person that
testified against me he disappeared
he disappeared the government couldn't
uh couldn't show in the final in the
final court dates
um and like the the lawyer i had because
first the
the creditor that i was working for the
cartel had put me a lawyer
and they were telling me like hey we're
gonna get you out because you're a
really good element
uh don't worry about it we got you
covered five months pass bro
they left me by myself they took that
lawyer away and i was left
by myself you know just with with the
with the attorney that the government
gives
and this this attorney um he looked at
me and he's like
you know you got 80 of leaving prison
because if they don't show you
if this witness doesn't show up you're
gone like they don't have anything
against you
um at the end of the day they let me go
bro
um when i stepped when i was more scared
of going to the streets and staying in
prison because i had already gotten used
to in prison i had been in prison for
three years
and been in several in several rights
inside that i had done
i hadn't got a respect from people
because they knew that we were the first
ones to stand for the people
inside of prison it's very crazy bro
because i learned
in prison i learned how to be humble
because in prison there's a lot of
people that
when you when you get the power of the
prison like let's say when the cartel
because the cartel runs the prison right
when the cartel gives you the power he
the cartel will select a couple of
inmates that have more time that have
more respect from the rest of the
inmates
and they'll give them the power here you
guys are going to control prison you
guys are going to sell whatever you're
going to sell
and bro they made more than like they
probably made like
five hundred thousand dollars in two
months that's how much they make in
prison and i'm talking about a prison
like
six thousand inmates seven thousand
inmates these are big prisons and
they they start growing and they start
getting really arrogant because of
because they think that that power that
they have that they got
that's gonna save them from from the
whole prison but the whole prison gets
fed up because of their arrogance you
know because they don't keep themselves
humble
and in prison like everybody all the
smart people that i would talk to
i would ask them like hey what's what's
the best advice you can give me though
like how do you think i could survive in
here in prison
and and they would tell me like it's
easy bro just keep yourself humble
like don't don't whatever you're doing
here whatever you're you're able to
whatever whatever you get in here
whatever whatever type of power you're
getting here
keep yourself humble help help the
person that has less and keep yourself
humble because the people are gonna see
if you grow arrogant at the first moment
that they got the opportunity they're
gonna stab me bro they're gonna kill you
and that's what happened um but i i lost
the race now allah knows what he put
he put me in there because at the end of
the day i kept myself really hungry you
know i knew that i didn't have anything
because i didn't have family that
that's taking care of me i have nothing
when i was leaving the prison
uh uh an important figure from a very
big cartel
he asked me hey you got you got a lot of
reputation outside and you got a lot of
repetition here
what what would you what would you think
if i if i offered you a higher a high
position in a big big cartel it looks
like you have a lot of experience in the
streets and and you know this you know
this area
um i asked you know like because i knew
that
i had two things or i had to leave the
country
or get back in the fight because they
were they were eventually gonna they
were looking for me and i'm saying get
killed by these people
so i ended up accepting it you know i
said yeah well i'm gonna accept your
deal
normally when you're in a cartel like
you'll meet the person that's in charge
of the song
of the area you'll never meet the high
the
the real bosses that control the whole
game that are the bosses of the cartel
so
when i stepped out and they gave me they
gave me this contact
i want to see him and he's like he's
like hey uh are you ready to go for like
we're gonna we're gonna go for two weeks
i was like where are we going
he said we're going to to a different
state and i was like
i thought i was just going to meet the
person that was in charge of this region
he's like nah
you're going to go meet the the metal
medal you know
the big dude the big boss and i was like
all right
let's do it you know i wasn't afraid i
wasn't i wasn't scared and i was and i
knew that i i had to fight these people
um so they they take my cell phone away
they they they search me real good to
make sure that that
that i wasn't being follower or that the
government was gonna come
behind us and they disappeared me to
i don't even know where they took me bro
but they took me like really far away
um it took like five days for me to meet
this person and
we had a we we arrived where this person
was
but it took five days for him to give me
to give me attention you know that's how
you call it here
uh to get
ladies and gentlemen is the power of
shaytan bro
he was getting deep into it too always
does this bro
do you know how many how many times i
was playing call of duty with ahmed
late night and we were just giving dawah
randomly bro and there were people like
ready like shahada ready
and then their mom storms and being like
yo why are you up so late and they like
take the court out
too many times bro too many times
shaytan is
damn hard worker bro i i hope he um
freezes because
we oh
damn is he hitting you up is he coming
back bro
he was going in bro
he was going in
here's the thing bro laptop phone
right makes sense he had a desktop can't
really go out of battery
probably wi-fi could be
he's typing oh he is okay
brother gain life that is bro it's not
it's not a joke bro he wrote it's crazy
bro this never happens
damn still typing i told you bro
let's see what he says bro i'm telling
you bro like every single time bro like
we were doing that or like another guy
was like i want to do this right and his
his mom's a girl we got to go to church
and they just left
you know because when you play call of
duty bro it's like
all these people are broken right he
wrote that it never happened in my life
it only happened this one other time
when i was speaking to eddie
[Music]
hmm
hmm it's definitely
iblees mm-hmm
jeez bro i hope everything's good
because i'm like really talk i want to
hear the rest of it
he got me moist bro
hmm he didn't write what happened he
wrote it's crazy bro this never happens
it happened also when i was speaking
eddie um
okay let's see
man's typing again
power went out damn he said it never
happens
only one other time with uh with eddie
he said he's turning everything back on
all right all right inshallah
so do you guys we're keeping this uncut
there's
like there's a reason i'm not gonna like
when i edit it i'm not gonna put like a
transition
because there's an immense lesson in
this that
shaitaan whenever you're like on the
right path right there's hadith of the
prophet
of some said that iman is a or doubts is
a sign that you have high iman
i'm paraphrasing why because as the rami
always says right if you
rami always says you're not going to
wake up the next day and be stressed
that there's no unicorns
that that you know unicorns don't exist
why because you never believed in them
to begin with
but if you're having doubts about islam
maybe because you know this is there's
something here
this is it right so
shaytaan's gonna be after you guys
whenever you are you wanna love the
[Music]
that's most bro
that's crazy
geez well
yo what he was saying when he was in
prison he said that uh
he had that guy that was uh basically
telling him
like yo i can i know your future and all
this stuff i know like
this what is gonna happen like bro real
talk
why you keep sending this little period
i do that when i'm uh i get moments for
the coming up
oh okay that makes sense let me make
sense
excuse me a couple hours of editing bro
and like
yeah okay okay i'm just saying
but um dude it they
brought me back to i want to say like
19 years old 20 years old when i was
working at gnc
and this couple came in and when the
couple came in
they were looking for some kind of a
product and like usually i help people
out i told you this story by the way
but i'm gonna say here like usually i
always help people out like giving them
discounts
and then they were like oh we're looking
for this and they picked like the most
expensive
product i was like listen um that one is
ass
this one right here is way better it was
three times cheaper and i was like look
i haven't got you guys with the uh
go-kart discount just to help you out
today and they were like oh wow like
thank you so much they were very
appreciative
but then his girl was like the dude's
girl was like oh
um i'm a i'm a psychic
and in my head i was like
yeah okay and she was like oh
like i can give you a reading and i was
like
by the time i was like sure go ahead
give me the reading and bro this chick
had told me that i had uh that i had
this dark
shadow that was following me i would be
lying bro
she said that and then she said she said
the first
letter of like the girl that like
supposedly was gonna be like the love of
my life i don't even remember what the
letter was to be honest with you
but i remember that she said the shadow
thing and like when i was
starting this whole new age stuff and uh
i had quote unquote open my third eye
and i remember walking into a room and
when i turned the light on bro there was
this dark
shadow in the corner bro and it's like
there's no way bro subhanallah there's
no way that there was a shadow not in
this room but it was
imagine you got this room you see like
that corner imagine
that just being a black shadow there's
nothing that could cause a black shadow
but there's just a black shadow
right there i remember i seen it and my
whole body
locked up and i was feeling all these
bro all these waves just going up and
down my spine when i seen that black
shadow and it's like
when i as soon as i can move my body and
i ran out
i i knew right from the rip like what i
just saw
was exactly what that chick had said was
following me bro
bro as soon as you did it says zach
gonzalez has entered the waiting room
guys if you made it this far man come on
smash that like button bro let's get
this brother back in
and on how man you say that a lot of
people won't believe you but
going through some of the things i went
through in my life this is real man
people don't believe in gin
100 and by the way before i put them in
what's the cut off time for you today
max time you can go on for
uh listen he's got me moist so let me go
for a little bit
all right bismillah
bro
you you had us bro you had us moist and
then you just dropped out
and it's crazy man because it's it's not
like when i was on the dean show brother
this
same thing happened bro this never
happens to me here i pay for a
high-speed internet and if you heard at
the end of the at the end of the lady
show
like my my communication got really bad
you know he's mad bro he's mad and i've
been going through some hard times but
believe me like
it's not easy it's not easy especially
being alone but
i'm not lost the greatest my brother and
i know that we're not
we're not in the wrong we're not on the
wrong path bro you know
i've noticed that that when when you're
not on the on the right path
shaytan doesn't come and bother you when
you're doing what he wants he won't
bother you bro he'll let he let you live
with the life that you want
but once you start striving to become
something good once you're striving to
do the right thing
that's when the real war starts bro but
we're warriors you know
you can do whatever you want it's very
yes sir
all right please continue continue
i was telling you guys um so they take
me to to uh
with to meet this this boss boss you
know
and it's it's very high
like these guys aren't playing around
that like when i
i didn't i didn't know to what extent i
was getting involved with right because
like i said i went
with several cartels it's very rare for
you to meet the actual
the actual bosses of the cartels the
real people that are in charge
and behind everything um so when they
take me to to meet this person you know
like that was in the middle of nowhere
um two
two bikes come riding up right with some
huge antennas and
a bunch of radios and they ride in like
they're like oh he's he's already coming
and i started seeing like 10 trucks
passport
like filled with people with rpgs and 50
calories bro
and and once like it was there it was
like
easily it was like 50 trucks that were
just like taking care of this person
he came in he came in in a bulletproof
badass car like a really nice car
brother
he got off and i'm talking to you about
an old man he's like 60
tall with the rolex you know
filled with diamonds and this guy was
he was like bro just imagine the cartel
that i was getting involved with right
i had no idea like i thought like i've
always been like
very uh like they
tell me like i've heard this with a lot
of cartels like oh we're working with
this cartel
and but it's at the end it's just a
small group that is taking the name
to make other young young young uh young
people work you know
they they wash their brains and they
tell them oh you're working for this
cartel but you don't see power bro
and when i went with those people that's
power like that is real cartel power
so we start talking any type so so
you're
so you're this this person you know i
had a nickname back then
um he's like you're this person they
told me a lot about you this they've
told me that
when you were in the house you were
you're a good worker and when you were
inside
prison then you handled your business
quite quite brave
what a brave little man because i'm not
that tall right but
yeah i'm like well yeah you know we're
here and he's like you're waiting to
work with me and i'm like yeah well
what is it that you guys want me to do
he's like well you're gonna you're gonna
go start
you're gonna go start a war with with
the rival cartel and this rival cartel
can i say the name or do you guys you
guys don't want to say the name of it
it's really famous bro
you do you bro do you bro we're cool
with that
you know cgn the mentor against them
because their their cartel
is their cartel is has no respect for
family bro
there's just a golden rule in in the
mafia you know you don't you don't kill
innocent people you don't touch
you don't touch family members you know
you go with the person that that's in
trouble you don't go take his family out
and and that that cartel is dirty
brother
like they'll take your whole family
they'll make stew out of your whole
family
that's there's no respect in what they
do um the cartel that i had joined
the reason i joined this cartel was
because they were against
crystal meth right you know crystal
methods is poisoning the the young minds
right now that's that's like
that's the cocaine for the poor right so
i was against that because i would see a
lot of a lot of
a lot of my brothers following that
addiction and when you're in the
when you're when you're working when
you're when you're operating there you
need to you need to be right in your
mind bro you can't have
a crystal meth person riding with you
like
he might panic and kill and get all of
you guys killed you know so they were
very picky on the people that you that
you that you would ride with because you
know that you're gonna you're gonna get
into a backfire
and you don't need people that are gonna
panic
are gonna start doing something that
might get you killed or might get you in
a bad position
so i was against that in the way that i
would see i was seeing how the the
society was getting destroyed by crystal
man
like there was no more respect for him
for anybody um
so that's why i decided to join this
cartel because i basically they wanted
to start
they were in a war where there's there's
still an award there's a there's a big
war going on down here brother
like everybody but basically all the
cartels are going against this car top
one i just mentioned
this is the cartel that nobody likes
because of the same reason because they
have no respect
um so when he tells me this he's like
are you are you ready to fight i'm like
yeah he's like well you know why you're
here
right i'm like yeah they they informed
me of basically what
what you want he's like i'm gonna give
you 20 people
armed and everything ready to go i'm
gonna give you five trucks and he pulled
out a bag
he pulled out a bike we pulled out like
half a million
and he stacked here go work
he's like this is a real cartel you
ain't you ain't working for no need for
no little kid cartel you're not you're
not working for no little organization
this is a real cartoon this is power
and i was like uh what am i getting
myself into man
you know because you know you know when
when these people have power they have
powerful like
they ain't playing around so i started
seeing the the structure of the cartel
there's no way that that that they're
gonna get on that
you understand why they're still there
why they're still there because it's
it's it's just a lot of intelligence and
you have to have a lot of brain to be
behind that wheel you know
um so he's like i want you to show me
like what you're about
go do your work and i start i start
working back then i was i was really
like i would tell the people that i was
writing with right i'm telling them hey
i'm not going with that person that's
back there man i'm i'm not loyal with
the cartel i'm one with the people that
are here with me
that are sitting here and writing with
me because i've been in prison bro and
i've seen how these people leave you
when you
when you fall in prison so we're riding
together we're getting out of this
together or you better not get in the
charge
so they would understand that aspect
because like i was a person that was
coming out of prison
i knew what prison life was and i knew
that there's no question
when you found when you found prison
called cartels leave you brother
you're they'll just pick another person
and put them in your position and they
won't even worry about it
so i knew what i was getting involved in
and all these these people that were
with me like they started they started
respecting them
because i was straight with them and i
wasn't lying i wasn't thinking oh
i'm here i'm gonna treat them like like
like they were
they're working for me i was like nah
i'm here to start work with these people
because these because
at the end of the day these people were
the people that had killed my my brother
right
these people were the ones that had gun
down my brother in front of his family
the the same cartel that i mentioned so
i had a lot of hate towards them
i started getting involved with this
from from 20 people i started i started
controlling over the over more than 100
150 people
no that's how strong my unit was and and
compared to the whole cartel
the cartel were working for probably
more than 50 000 strong man
these guys are no joke like when they
had meetings you would see 200 300
trucks
filled with with military tactical
people like they ain't playing around
with the little with the little handgun
they playing like
you're gonna carry yourself you're gonna
carry yourself you're gonna carry
yourself at least with
five mags six mags eight mags ready to
fight you know you're ready to die there
because you yeah that's why that's why
you're there
and that's what we started getting me
like recognizing that i was gonna die
you know because like a lot of people
don't think about death you know that's
we have we try to keep it back here in
the back of our mind
like we don't want we don't want to
think about that day
but alhamdulillah brother allah made me
the type of person that i don't fear
death bro i'm like i don't fear this
like even today like they tell me
because i get threats from them you know
tell me we're going to find him
bro i know i'm on the right path if
you're going to kill me you're going to
you're going to make me go see my
creator sooner than other people
alhamdulillah i have no i have no fear
against these people
but back in back in the day when i was
working for it for this for
these big for these people like i would
think to myself
like i know that i can die any moment
and it wasn't like
it wasn't encounters like small
encounters it was gunfights up to 40 50
minutes
gunfights and and you would see who like
you would see who are real men like you
will see
who are the boys and who are the men and
you see much men turn into boys and
little boys turn into men
because you know when when when someone
is is into that you know like real
warriors like
they're ready to fight a lot of people
just talk to talk but they can't walk
the walk
and and i knew i could talk the talk and
i could walk the walk and that's what
really scared me bro because i was like
you're gonna die you're gonna die here
because you know it's like bro
this is not forever and we know this
like there's there's a rule
in the cartels nothing is forever you're
gonna you're gonna end up in prison for
the rest of your life or you're gonna
end up getting shot by the government
because the government here
the military when you encounter them
they kill you bro
they ain't going to tell you they're
going to tell you like you're going to
get under arrest did you guys see the
video that
that came out um they got into a
gunfight in damon
military killed like over like 14 cartel
members
you guys should watch that i just do
have an understanding like how is
how is the fight it's not they don't
they don't they don't fight like they're
gonna arrest you
they fight like they're gonna terminate
they're gonna eliminate the
cancer because at the end of the day
like i know there i understand what
they're coming from you know
they're trying to they're trying to get
rid of this this poison that's that's
poisoning the whole
the whole society but getting involved
in this like several several times i i i
got
uh how do you call it i got um i'm
looking for that word
like they set me up and they tried
killing me a couple of times
there were several times bro where there
was one specific time that i remember
that um
they started shooting us from behind you
know um we didn't even see where the
where the boys were coming but we
like the bullets are just shattering the
the back window
and we were in a road in a in a road
that was it wasn't it wasn't concrete
it was a dirt road so you know in a dirt
road a car going a
high velocity you can't control it and a
little bit that you move your steering
wheel without knowing how to drive
in those type of roads it's going to
slip and it's going to crash
so that's what that's what happened i
ended up hitting myself against a tree
and i remember that the seatbelt so when
i used to work like i used to pull the
seat belt and just click it
and then just push pull the top one over
me like that because i would have my
rifle right here where i would have it
on this side
but i know i knew that if anything
happened i just put it up and pull up my
rifle and get to it you know
that day i don't know what happened like
with the with the with the
hit of the like with the crash i kind of
like
i started right um and i i the first
thing i did i pulled i clicked on the on
the seat belt but the seat belt was
still stuck on me
and i and i had my plate my my auntie
check my my bullet my bulletproof vest
and i had my magazine and it was really
stuck on me right and i couldn't move
and i remember i started hearing like
the bullets the bullets started hitting
like real close to the to the steering
wheel
and i remember i just put my hands down
and i was like looking at my stomach
just waiting for the bullet to come
through right
i like this it you know this is it let's
go
there's nothing else to do i lost i lost
this but
like i said alhamdulillah alas
we ended up fighting we ended up
recalling the fight like the the ambush
and we got out of there um and a lot of
my friends were talking like damn like
you're
you're lucky you're a lucky person bro
because like
like we because we had encountered so
much so much danger
that anybody else like in that situation
would have probably just like
they would have probably had someone
injured you know but every time we would
go out and we'd get shot at or
get into gunfights all the people that
were with me would come back safe
none of us and we would see other
members from from from other teams
that they would come back without their
arms you know because like they get hit
by
by big caliber events uh they would come
back really messed up you know
um and that's when my my mind started
asking myself like
you know you're gonna die you're not
afraid of it okay you got that point
but what's after death like what's the
explanation of being here like why am i
here
i'm smarter than this i'm smarter than
being with these with with these cartels
because at the end of the day you don't
you don't have a life you serve a cartel
you serve a purpose for them
and and you're going to die for them for
these people that don't that don't
respect you they don't they're not loyal
to you they're just using it at the
moment
um and the crazy thing was that
we would go up to the mountain ranges
right so it right here the car tells us
this is how they work
when they when they go into a city
they'll go into a city like that
two in the morning we'll go into the
city we'll we'll let it we'll let the
sun rise and then we'll go out and we'll
do our business and then come back out
and go back into the mountains and
we'll drive like into the mountains like
three four hours make sure that we're in
our territory where they have everything
controlled
there's where there's a communications
so anything like if the military is
coming in
just pick up your stuff get on the car
and just drive around them you know
you you don't you're not that exposed of
getting getting into gunfights so when i
was in when i was there when i was in
the mountains like i would look at the
mountains and it's very beautiful here
like the mountain ranges you know and i
would ask myself like who created this
there has to be there has to be
something else you know there has to be
something else
like where where am i going to end up
when i die
it's easy to die that's the easy part
but what's there to come you know that
was my question like myself i was going
to that
situation that what was there to come
after that
i got to the point where i started
seeing weird things happening in
in our in our group another another uh
another cartel member a
high-ranking member came and he started
like trying to mix people up
at the end of the day i found out he was
trying to like he was trying to see what
i was doing you know
so he could memorize the roots and
everything so he could kill me
and then just take over everything like
get make his group bigger but
with taking out taking me out by
infiltrating his people
into my group the good thing was that
the the people that he infiltrated like
they respected me because they were
telling me like there were similar
situations but we would get down
and him being a leader he ran bro you
know
he ran he left his people and i stayed
with these people and i i ended up
uh i ended up getting his people out of
there we ended up getting into a big
gunfight
and and after that they would tell me
like we got a lot of respect for you
like
you're a fighter you know you ain't like
that's why we're here you know
that's what i thought i was there for
but when i started seeing that things
were just getting out of hand
i was saying you know what i'm out of
here i'm dropping everything i'm just
gonna bounce
i left the cartel like at three in the
morning bro just got my stuff
drove off i didn't even know where i was
gonna go that's how crazy it was whether
i didn't even know where i was gonna end
up i just drove
ran out of gas got bought a ticket a bus
ticket
got to the other side of the country got
to a place where nobody knew me you know
and that's where where i started getting
depressed because of the life that i
used to have to the life that i was
living now
back in back there i would never i would
never be with empty pockets oh i would
always carry money you know because i
was working for the cartels and
so there's always money involved either
you're stealing it you're
you're getting it from from my members
that are paying or government
there's so many there's so many illegal
activity there that you would
you would eventually give money and
basically like he paid
he he would send me the the the payments
for every single for every single
soldier
so i would i would pay him every month
you know
and and i started getting depressed with
myself because like that's when shaytan
started coming in and telling me like
like that you're a coward i you would
you would stand up straight with the
homeboys down
down there and you were telling me you
were ready to die and look where you're
at
you ran away from from death you know
you ran away from from that life when
you said you were
you were you were who you were but then
it got to the point where i was no
longer able to
to understand what was always there you
know um
it got really you got really dark bro
like really like and imagine a person
like me that's been in that
that type of scenery i've never quite
brother like i've never shown any
any feelings for nothing that i've done
before and and and in that point that i
was in my life
i just couldn't bear you know and in
prison i learned how
how to hang yourself you can like you
can kill yourself just
from the doorknob if you really want to
kill yourself you know
i don't see people inside take their
lives and in prison you find people with
100
80 90 years of prison they're never
going to come out so they eventually
take their life
and got to that point where i was like
thinking to myself like
just take your life you haven't done
anything you haven't done anything good
in this world
like there's nothing for you here like
what do you deserve you know
that those mind games that shaytan comes
and plays with you
there's no there's no reason for you to
stay here you you've you've left the
people that you said you were going to
be loyal to it
and you didn't die like the warrior that
you were supposed to you were supposed
to uh
go i would always admire people like
there's there's a there's a famous uh a
famous couple his his uh
his name is anfield uh
he was uh he was that type of person
that would say he was gonna die fighting
and at the end of the day he killed
himself
against the government with his people
you know he died and that's that's how i
saw my life
i i would tell people like i want to die
that way you know i'm gonna die fighting
because
i'm a warrior that's how corrupt my
mentality was you know
and i didn't know i really didn't know
what i wanted when i got to that point
where
i was really like just too sick of my
life and sick of what i had done
i i ended up you know like just breaking
you know crying crying
desperately because i didn't know what
to do i didn't find
anything in my life that was valuable
anymore before i would say like i'm
still alive because i'm fighting with
these people or i'm fighting for a good
cause i wasn't fighting for no good
cause i was fighting for
to get these people rich you know doing
their dirty business um
and and i remember like completely like
i was already looking for the road but i
was making the night man
and i was looking i was looking around
like working i came where can i hang
myself from you know
and i just sat on my bed and crying
brother like
crying i sat on my bed and i i just
looked up and
asked you know ask i asked
if you're listening to me and you're
seeing me give me guidance
guide me to something that is true
because i don't know what i don't know
what's going on
and i'm going to lose myself and i'm
going to lose everything
i didn't call upon anything else but
that i just said that
and i closed my eyes if you really exist
if you're out there if you're
if there's something real in this world
guide me
take me to a truth i didn't know that
that like now that i'm a muslim i'd be
like
how why did i ask for guidance you know
like i didn't know i didn't know like
that's why when i when i talk about this
like i get very emotional because
it's very powerful brother like imagine
like not nobody came to
nobody came to give me dog had no clue
about about islam
everything i knew about islam is what
the west shows you you know they took
down the
the the twin towers and that they're a
bunch of terrorists
that they think different but in reality
i didn't know where this found was
when i asked for this you know i i i
controlled myself and i said
i'm not going to kill myself today i
threw the rope and i
went back to bed i remember before going
to bed man i
i clicked on my arm clicked on youtube
and i was looking for something to hear
you know something just to relax
and i don't know where the i saw a uh
recitation from the quran and i i looked
at it and i was like
and you know those black screens where
it's just the quran it's recitating the
crime but no no nothing on
nothing on the screen and i was like
i'm gonna see what this is and i clicked
on it
brother like i can't
share with you what happened my heart
just started going like
it was breaking bro like breaking and i
was crying i wouldn't know why
i didn't know why i was crying like i
was i would cry because of the
recitation i didn't know what it meant
but i was crying you know like
[Music]
what am i listening to
khabib was going to fight right this
happened
when this when he retired bro like
i remember i started i started um i'm a
real i'm gonna i'm gonna
ah i'm really into mma bro
i go and i train i train my time i
fought through
and that's what got my attention brother
uh he was
he demonstrated what a warrior is bro a
wearing arrogant a warrior's home when
he's ready to die and he stands for what
he believes in you know
um he's come he's out of the ballpark of
anybody that you can you can't compare
with anybody
because nobody does what he do what he
does you know and that's what
when i remember i was sitting down i had
already listened to the recitation but i
didn't know what it meant
and and i was doing my own investigation
trying to find out what it was you know
like i got invited to see the fight and
i i was looking at the fight and
everything was good you know um he ended
up choking out gage you know with the
triangle
and he just completely broke because he
had lost his father right
but when he got up that was very
emotional to me when he started pointing
to the sky
first of all i want to say alhamdulillah
alhamdulillah
bro i started crying like what what does
this mean you know what
i remember i typed it on the computer
looking for the meaning of the hunger
all praise be to god and i was like i
started getting goosebumps on my
like on myself you know i feel like man
what is this i'm not gonna lie to you
bro
before i watch that fight i had a dream
and in that dream i had five fights and
at the end of the fight i would i would
yell
allow it but allow it but bro literally
bro i know what that man brother
and i was younger in my dream and i was
like what the like what's going on in my
life you know
bro this is real man we we know
when this is real my brother
oh this religion is real when it comes
to your love for guiding me to this
because there's nothing more real than
this brother
when i started seeing when i started
like i started seeing his his
um have you seen the anatomy anatomy of
the fighter
when they go to uh when they go to
dagger step
i would see how they were they would put
religion first how he would say
for me this is not important for me it's
important my religion
my creator being grateful with my
creator how she's i will see a
humbleness that i don't see in much
people like i don't see many people
you can have a lot of knowledge bro but
you can come you you can act very
arrogant you know even if you're
even if you're seeing the truth you come
out really arrogant
and and that's why i i bro i follow your
channel
and i i've been following you guys
because when i when i see you guys
you guys are humble brother you guys
don't forget who we are and you guys
don't forget that we're gonna die at the
end of the day you know
and we're gonna stand in front of our
creator this this dunya is nothing
this world is nothing and it should have
no meaning to us you know
we have to stay humble and and
that itself was like a turning point in
my life
i i took the shahada without nobody
looking at me bro just looking at a
video like
like it was crazy brother like i was
like what am i getting myself into you
know because there's no
no one to talk to about this man just
myself and
i started finding peace bro i started
finding peace i started finding a
meaning towards my life
like i said i don't know why i lived i
have lived this life
now that i'm a muslim i understand why i
understand
that allah has plans for every single
one of us and
he lets us walk until we we we break and
we
we turn around and look at him and we
accept that he's he's above
everything else and that we only need
him we don't need anybody else we don't
need no human we just need him
and when i started getting involved in
this like by myself man
i started looking up a lot of uh uh
uh uh dawg material people that were
giving dollars because i was hungry i
was hungry to learn about
about the religion you know what it
really meant to be a muslim
and every time i would i would like
listen to the stories of abu bakr
um the companions of of the prophet i
would cry rather like omar you know how
he got killed at the end
and he was not afraid of dying and that
would break my heart brother because i
was
i was ready to die bro i was literally
ready to die for
all the wrong reasons and the people how
these people left this world brother
like that gives goosebumps to someone
that was ready back for
all the wrong reasons bro and i would
listen to the stories of the companions
of the prophet peace be upon him
and people that are born as muslims are
lucky
they're very lucky to to have this type
of
this type of religion because it's we
have the perfect examples bro
of how we should act every day you know
and hearing these stories would brighten
you know knowing how they would
they would go to war and how the
companions would die in work
and i was like man like i've been
following something that wasn't right
and i now i know what's my call calling
now i know that i have to i have to
strive to be a better muslim
brother when i started when i started
becoming a muslim you know
it got really it got really difficult
like
tests started coming you know
like i said shaytan is not happy
when you when you're doing when you're
striving
i remember i lost my job and things
started going downhill
when i lost my job we were like
i remember like i i received the call
like oh we can't
we can't continue employing you this is
that
i just hanged up and i i remember i
wrote my hand and i was like
it's like you know living alone and
having to take care of yourself by
yourself and
losing your job is like losing where
you're living and you know going to the
streets if you don't find a job and it
was during the pandemic during the cold
situation
but nobody was hiring you know it was
just difficult for everybody
and i remember when that happened i was
like
and i kept repeating that to myself
the next day i get a call from from
cartels from cartoon members down there
and they start saying hey i we
want you to come back you know i want
you to work for us
i have i have some i have so many
connections in different cartels
but but because they know that how i
used to be you know they knew how i used
to
how i used to act they were giving me
that opportunity
to to to go back to the cartels that
they were going to give me high
positions because
of of all the fame and all the the the
paperwork that i put in you know all
that all that work that i put in was
that was backing me up you know and it
got to the point where
i was seeing all these like the the
shaytan was testing like shaytan was
attacking me this way
because he knew i didn't have a job
because he he knew that that
that maybe maybe my my the part of my
part of me that was still back in that
life
like still still trying to hold on to
that life
wanted to go back to it and believe me
it was hard bro like i literally had to
think about it you know i had to sit
down and think to myself
are you going to turn your back on your
lord now that he has sent you to
now that he has guided you to something
that is true because like
us as muslims we read the quran and we
see how many miracles are in the quran
brother that are
mind-blowing you know that just blow
your mind you say like oh my god
how did prophet muhammad peace be upon
him knew this you know this could not be
just an invention of his
it couldn't be it can't be something of
his creation there's something greater
than
there's something great in there and
that's why like
we have we have to value the guidance
that we have by our lord because you
show this to a non-muslim
and they look like they look for any
excuse you know they look for anything
excuse to
just say like bro they're blind brother
they're blind looking at the sun saying
that the sun is not there you know
and and it's like man i
i knew that i wasn't on something very
real
and then if i turn my back on my lord i
was not going to come back
and i and i i really talked to myself
and think and think to myself
okay like because a part of me was like
you know that it's a struggle you know
it's not like you're gonna change
one day to another you're gonna lose
your bad habits you know
i was still like something was still
trying to pull me like come on
that's that's that's what you do that's
you're good at that it's gone
it could have been easy to go do my
business and came back with my needs so
i just try to live myself
but i was like nah i can't i can't i
just can't like
and then reading reading the verse you
know read the verses of the crime where
it says that
he guides who he wills and he lets go
straight who he wills
i was like nah if i'm guiding this for
something like i can't
i can't just turn my back or my back on
my creator when when
he heard me when i was on on my lowest
point because most of us
and i'm gonna i'm gonna say this
personally brother
like when you get comfortable with when
you're in a position that that that
our lord has taken on us from we get
comfortable and we say
we don't need him anymore and we start
leaving the things that we need to do
like praying like fasting like giving
glory to his name
appreciating where we're at bro and this
happens to every muslim
like and i'm saying this because of me
you know like i get comfortable
and i stopped and like i stopped i
stopped striving to be a better muslim
and i think to myself like man
and it's it's amazing when when you feel
that here you can
like you feel bad right you're like i
can't i have to go back
and and shaytan tells you like nah you
know
you're gonna go back and you know you've
done you've done this now you just did
this and this is this is against your
lord like you're gonna just go run back
at him
it's a it's a it's a mind game brother
and it's a war that we have
against shaytan and it's not gonna it's
it's never gonna end until the day we
die
but until the day we die where that war
is gonna end
but alhamdulillah he's hearing me
he gave me a really strong character and
and i thank him for
for everything he's put me in because i
needed to walk that life to understand
and to appreciate this religion with
with my heart you know
this is everything for me at the end of
the day like my family my family are not
muslims bro
and i talk to them like and that's what
vessel really hurts when you have
families that are
muslims and you share the message with
them and they they turn a blind eye
towards them you know
and you ask yourself what's going to
happen in the day of judgment when you
see your family standing
next to you and they're not gonna
they're they're not because we're
striving you know
and and it's it's it's something really
hard to to know that
at least we have we have we have an
opportunity
there's still something there that could
save us you know because none of us are
perfect but there's something there that
that means that we could still be saved
because we were guided
we were guided for a reason bro we were
guided for a reason nobody's perfect you
know
but when just to see your family members
turn a blind eye on this religion it
hurts bro
and like i i i love my brother right
and my brother he looks up to me because
he knew that like
i was involved in that and and and like
he has his guns and he hasn't he
he's living a really good life you know
and and the other day i was talking to
him and i was trying like
see secret creator brother like secret
creator and he's like you know what i'm
gonna tell you something
like don't talk to me about god and
broke my heart bro cause i was like
all right but let me just tell you
something
is my life not testimony enough to tell
you that there's a creator bro
that there's a purpose for me still
standing here
is this not enough to show you that
there's a creator man i
you knew i was gonna die i'm gonna tell
you guys something i was reported dead
right
the government down there they reported
me dead because they had found that they
had gotten into a gunfight with another
cartel
they killed the people that were in the
in that convoy
and one of those those people reflected
my face
i don't know how the news got to my
family in the states
they were ready to send my my sisters
because they were going to bury me
and my brother was crying everybody was
fine and i remember like
i received a call from someone and
they're like hey like
are you okay i'm like yeah what i bro
everybody's saying you got killed like
look and they sent me the picture that
the person looked like you know but a
little bit
you know when when the person dies he he
gets
swollen and they're like they're saying
it's you
and i remember like i was like damn i'm
gonna call my mom
i call my mom and my mom when she
answered the phone my mom
my mom fainted she dropped the phone and
my brother picked up the phone and my
friends like who is this
like it's me zach what are you talking
about he's like you're dead
you're dead like i'm seeing the picture
right now you're dead i'm not
dead bro but then i i i i was kind of
like
i was i was feeling like i had feelings
against them you know
and i remember i told them like
we was just needed from to to understand
that you have a brother
that to understand that you because i
felt like i felt like i didn't have any
more family because they no longer
they know they no longer look for me
they no longer
work for me you know i was on my own
they were worried about their life but
they weren't worried about me but now
that i ended up
supposedly dying like now they want to
worry about me now they want to bury me
and i told my brother i remember i was
doing the cartels and i told my brother
like hey
if i die let me get in by the dog man
let me get in by the dogs because you
haven't
when i ask you for help you turn your
back now now that you know that i'm dead
that i died like now you want to come
and cry
don't do that man yeah it was the wrong
thing to say at the moment you know
but now that that i that i'm here and
now that i'm standing here
talking to you guys like i i feel bad
though like i feel bad when i'm
where my brother says that and i tell
him like come on man
is my life not like i tell my like i
tell them what i've been through
because like in order for me to tell you
guys everything i've been through it's
like i have to
take 10 hours about to tell you
everything every single thing that i've
been through and how
a lot has kept me safe but basically i'm
i'm just trying to keep this short
um and i tell my brother this and i tell
my mom and my mom just she
she's like yeah well think i think the
lord you know but she doesn't accept she
doesn't want to accept
she doesn't want to accept the religion
she she's good like she is right now
because she doesn't go
anywhere but she's in the back of her
mind she's like i thank god that they're
okay but
but they don't they they don't um
[Music]
they don't see it that way bro you know
they don't they don't
i appreciate it because i was guided by
myself when i was in my lowest point
where there was when there was no one to
tell me you know what this is the right
path
because a lot of a lot of preachers from
from the christian community
from the from the jehovah witness i
remember in prison they would trying to
go up to us and tell
us like they were trying to preach to us
and i remember i would always like
come up with some some stuff that wasn't
i wasn't even supposed to say to them
but i would make fun of the religion you
know
basically like tommy your bible is
corrupted because i've never been
i've considered myself an intelligent
person like obviously before before
going into something i'm going to
investigate you know
and doing your investigations you can
tell that the bible's corrupt
there's there's evidence there's a lot
of evidence to show that the bible's
prophet
and that they're on the wrong path and
and just just the way that they try to
explain
their their their belief it doesn't make
sense it doesn't make sense
and islam very simple and is very direct
you know
and and sometimes i hear people trying
to sweet talk islam
islam shouldn't be a dagger to the heart
bro die it's hard for people to
understand that
this is not a game this is this is our
life you know this is
i think that they were all gonna die and
we have to appreciate what we're getting
invited to and a lot of people don't
understand and that's why my necessity
right now like i'm working on on things
right now to like obviously i can't give
them dawah
i'm no one brother i have no knowledge
but i can't be that that that bridge
between between people that have
knowledge
and the people that are in prison you
know trying to trying to to put that
seed in
in their hearts like they like like the
seed was planted made by by
uh by when he pointed up to the sky and
when i started hearing the quran you
know
like those little things change you know
many a lot of people a lot of muslims
talk about about khabib because
what he does that's his problem between
him god you know who are we to judge
for no one to judge about it but because
of him i'm here
and i'm always like i've always liked
thoughts i'm like man i was guided by
her
like hearing like seeing this guy
fighting and noticing that every time he
fought every time
he would give glory to god bro it had
something very incredible like i said
man i wish i could i wish i could meet
khabib one day in town
thanks bro what you do it means a lot
you know
especially to to someone like like like
me you know
i consider myself a hardcore criminal
you know like no someone that has no
fear and
i have no fear in in that aspect that i
had no fear and
whatever were the consequences i knew i
was already
i knew i was already way over my head
and i was
in in like i'm sorry to say this but i
was
in the [ __ ] bro i was in the [ __ ] you
understand this
i was where there's where there's
nothing bro i was in the very bottom of
society of everything you can say
and it's amazing how how things come out
to work
like now that i'm a muslim like i think
about all my dead friends right
and i say to myself what makes me what
made me so special
what made me so special to be guided to
this and not them
why did i get guided i should have died
with them
i shouldn't die with my friend i should
have died with my friends you know
because
like you understand that in this life
you don't have many friends you know
like before you go before you get into
muslim i know muslims we don't consider
ourselves friends we consider ourselves
like brothers we're brothers to each
other but when you're in that life when
you're when you're out of this one
you know that there's no friends bro the
people that really show you loyalty and
they're they're
really with you the people that are
willing to die with you
the people that are ready to ride with
you you know and and i appreciated that
kind of
that kind of brotherhood that i had back
in the back in those days
because of the same because of what i'm
telling you your friends are there just
while you're
able to give them a benefit while they
have advantage of you
once you they don't have advantage of
you but maybe they run
they turn your back on you when you
don't have nothing to give them you know
and and we have to appreciate those type
that type of a brother i'd rather have a
brother that's going to tell me straight
up to my face you know what you're doing
this why are you doing this [ __ ]
this one and have someone that's going
to talk about on my back and saying
let's be talking about me
oh he's laughing about you like oh this
person is doing this and wrong
you say you love me if you say you're my
brother tell me in my face
and that's how we we would be back then
you know back when we were when we were
writing in the
we would tell ourselves we would be
straight up you know
with things and i'm really appreciative
i'm
i gave oh i give all glory and i give
out glory to my creator
allah because if i hadn't walked the
life i'd walk bro i wouldn't have the
type of
values that i have being humble being
loyal
i wouldn't have that bro and and now
that i see
like i see okay i wouldn't be the type
of person i am now i know that
i i get threats all the time right but
x-cartel members are like oh we're going
to get you i come and get me man it
means
you guys ain't gonna come get no no new
kid you know like obviously
i'm gonna defend myself but
come on man like now i understand that
a lot of people say like you should get
out of mexico you should run to another
country
why i'm gonna stand firm and i'm i'm
gonna i'm gonna make sure that other
people get guided to this to this
religion because this is the truth
i ain't gonna be no character on my back
turn my back on my people because
i still have people bro loyal people
that
that are all that are like they call me
they tell me like how are you man
i'm doing good bro and they they they
they ask they tell me like hey
i hope god blesses you know not even not
them knowing about islam
i've tried to talk to several of my
friends like those hardcore friends
but they tell me like come on man you
believe you're a saint
like now that you're in the religion you
think you're saying like you know what
we've done
you ain't no saint i thought i'm not i
know i'm not the saying brother like
i know i'm not saying but there's
something different like
there is a different way to walk man we
don't have to watch the way we
when we were walking you know now a lot
of kids that are involved in
in that um in that criminal life
they think that that's the only way to
walk but if they turn
if they turn around and they did they
take a decision to walk a different way
that people are going to make fun of
them know that people that the people
that they're working for are going to
make fun of
who cares man this is it's your life at
the end of the day you're gonna die by
yourself
no one's gonna hold your hand and die
with you like oh stay with me come
i'm gonna die with you no when you die
you go by yourself when we stand up
in front of our creator we're gonna be
by ourselves no one is going to talk for
us
we're going to talk for us so we have to
we have to take that decision to walk
that way
and right now like i said i'm working on
that um
trying to get some some dowel material
in spanish down there
with with the homeboys some of them
are have already understood you know i'm
glad
because i they tell me like
like what made you change man like
i don't know where you just changed and
i and i told them the necessity of
knowing what's on the other side
because at the end of the day that's the
only thing that we have guaranteed that
we're going to die
there's nothing else people trying to i
try to keep that every day you know like
i wake up and i think to myself
i can die today you know i can die today
i can walk outside and get into an
accident or
they can find me and we're going to get
down and i'm going to end up dying i can
die today
and i was back in my days i was going to
die every day you know i'm going to die
for all the wrong reasons
now that i'm alive now and then i'm here
i tell my i tell my friends like hey man
i you know that what we've done is bad
you know you know that
we've been into the garbage and that
we're gonna die
especially as you know especially the
people that have been like like living
the way we've lived
like the time like there's there's
nothing else here going for us but death
and and it's it takes a real map to to
accept his
his errors and turn to his creator a
real man
someone that's arrogant is not going to
look towards the sky he's not going to
look towards his
his creator someone that's arrogant
because oh because of me
because of me because of me someone that
feels like that bro they're never going
to turn they're never going to turn
around
and uh humbly a lot of god has given me
god let me see what it means to be
humble and i need to be humble to it in
order to
to understand that i have nothing what i
have is
is thanks to him because he's a he's my
protector he's our guider he's our
everything
and he this is i don't
i have a few words but because i'm not
i'm not a knowledgeable person
but to what i understand i need him more
than anything else
and i've uh i'm working on it you know
i'm working on
getting this message to them not me
specifically but being that bridge
between them you know
because they do need to help and in
order for mexico to change
the society here to mexico to change it
needs to change from the prison
because prison bro that's where you
where you that's we call it
you know in spanish it's a it's the word
for it this is a school
where you graduate with the name would
you graduate with honors
to become a big criminal or you flunk it
and you end up being an addict
you know a drug addict because there's
drugs inside like there's everything
inside
they're so corrupt in here that you you
could lose yourself
in drugs he's always kept me away from
that
and i graduated with honors but
with the honors that i needed in my life
to be a muslim right now
to say that i'm humble and i don't need
anything else i need him
and i need to follow his path you know
i'm the lover it's like it's it's
it's been a blessing you know and i'm
glad that i can like i can share this
with with people
when when uh when i spoke to eddie i i
sent him an email just like because i
felt my i felt really alone right like
there's nowhere to go here there's no
mosque there's no monsters no muslims
i'm basically here by myself and i don't
hang around with much people
here like i have friends obviously you
know there's people that know me
but they're always like why are you so
boring man
because every time like they invite me i
talk to them about god you know
hey i'm gonna turn around too great
because i i take that advantage to like
to plant that seed and i remember like
there was this bull one of my friends
he's like hey
go with me come with me i need to take
her some business and i don't know if
we're probably gonna get into a fight
and
i was like all right let's go when i was
already starting to become a muslim
right
and i connected my phone to his to his
to his radio and i started
i started blasting some some suit on his
brother like
and he was like he looked
oh no
bro two times bro but
it happened i think this happened on on
purpose purpose
because i gotta pray uh marketing let me
how about this bro
i'll be here you go pray maghrib and
come back
i'll be back
my man uh my man just messaged me uh
shaytan is not happy
and he's right
can you hear me brother what's going on
bro i could hear you bro so i'ma like
him
that's crazy man
[Music]
it hasn't happened to me since the
when i have the energy with the t-shirt
see the thing with me and angel is
after we got on deen the more you know
experiences we have the more we live
life the older we get
we're not even phased at these things
anymore you know like non-muslims
non-muslims will be like
or like completely like they don't even
believe right they're going to be like
oh you know that's that's not shaytan
what are you talking about that's the
internet glitch or powers out or
something you know
and the people that are you know they
believe but they don't really believe
they're going to be like oh uh nah
there's no way that's
you know there's no way that [ __ ] done
or or you know you
think you're overthinking it could just
be circumstantial right
there's nothing circumstantial in this
life
while angel gets back bro i had a quick
question so this whole
period of time that you were referring
to right which period of time was this
was this like last year
i've been out of the cartels
probably a year and a half bro
okay and you got on dean like what last
year
i got uh dean uh eight months ago
eight months
the fight with uh that was in october
right
i think so yeah september it was in that
time
where i started uh getting on the d so
when did you when did you take
[Music]
i remember bringing islam up to him in
last february right
so we went to a trip to iceland right
and bro yeah he's the thing bro
you know what you were talking about
when you get on dean you want to just
bring people to islam and you want to be
that guy
and other people are like oh it's this
guy like all he talks about right
so for me i'm passionate right but i'm
not
i'm gonna tell everyone about it right
um but him he's really close to me
you know we've been close for a couple
years alhamdulillah so when we went to
iceland we were just you know in the
kitchen one day just
you know making dinner um and we went
with the third brother but he was asleep
alhamdulillah and you know we were just
talking about god bro i don't know how
the conversation came
and we were talking about his upbringing
and him not really believing in
christianity and
he was talking about his grandpa back in
puerto rico right and
i told him about islam and it just it
just resonated with him
he gave me a little bit of like you know
like obviously it's like
completely new to it right but he's like
yeah bro i've been thinking about it and
like you know if there had to be one
like it makes sense
and you always have something have you
noticed that that's really funny bro
like
like i was a conspiracy junkie you know
like knowing who controls this world
everything goes back
to what the quran says when the two
angels came down
and bro everything is explained like
when i when i remember
when i was like when i was looking at
that when i was looking at those
conspiracies right i was like
i don't know i don't know if this is
true
at the end of the day these the people
that control this world brother you know
they're they're they worship shaytan
because this dunya is if this dunya is
nothing this dude is a task
there's nothing there's nothing about
this dunya that has any type of value
and like they look like looking at that
like i would ask myself like man
what does all this in everything would
end where it began bro where it began
and and when i when i listened to the
quran and when the crown was talking
about
when the angels went when allah sent the
angels uh to babylon you know to give
that that secret that those the secret
now that secret knowledge that's where
everything is coming from you know
this time everything makes sense bro
like if you truly want to want to accept
this game
there is nothing that is not explained
like like
the gins right when when when i turned
it when i
converted i had a experience with one
with the gym
because i used to worship i used to
worship the holy debt um
actually i have a tattoo of the whole
death here in my hand i have my
i have both of my hands tatted i have my
chest and my stomach
because i was really involved with that
and something really funny bro
like in prison remember i was talking
about this fortune teller
that told me that something was going to
happen to me and then i met the kid that
killed his girl with his c he killed his
girl inside
he told me he's like hey be careful
because you're gonna you're gonna
something's gonna happen to you bro the
when those four months ended
i had its weirdest dream and it's it's
something very incredible because the
lives bless me with dreams bro in my
life
for me specifically i don't know about
you if you've also had this type of
experience
but i've had i've been i've always asked
myself like why why do i have these
dreams like
sometimes you see that you're going
crazy right but bro
when i had this dream i wasn't a
believer in anything right um
in his dream i noticed myself in
close to the to the place where i spoke
to this fortune teller
and this fortune teller told me that i
was gonna that something was gonna
happen to me i was gonna die
in the dream brother i
i was in that area and i i was running
away from someone that was trying to
kill me
and he shot me in the face and shot me
in the arm and i ended up being on the
road
like dying right the paramedics came
have you seen those horror movies where
the people are just like still just
looking at like they're like there's no
emotions nothing in their face they're
just looking at you
i saw these people looking at me like
that and i was telling them like i'm
dying take them to the hospital
bro these people told me like just die
just die
i don't know where i get swallowed to
the ground and i end up
in a room in a dark room and in the
middle of the room there was a
there was uh the roots of a tree coming
down like that right but there was
everything was dark
and i looked towards the darkness and
something came out of the darkness right
and i started talking to
like what is it that you want in life
right and i told them
i remember i want power and i and i want
my freedom because i was in prison
he said i'm going to give you everything
you want but are
you ready or what are you willing to do
for them and i remember
i remember i asked my i asked i i
like bro allah is my witness i had no
fear bro to tell him
i'm not afraid of anything and i'll do
anything to to obtain that
and he's like i'm going to give you
everything go back up go back up to the
second one to my second dream
when i turn around in the roots like now
there was
there was a uh there was some there was
some steps some ladders going on
somewhat yeah that's how you call it
right
there was uh ladders going like no it's
not matters some stairs going up
around stairs going around the the rooms
of the tree
bro the the second part of the dream
where i ended up
that has no importance the importance is
these two dreams now look
look at this dream bro
i woke up and i didn't wake up like i
woke up and started moving no i woke up
and i just opened my eyes and i was
thinking to myself
why did i have this dream when i tried
to got up when i tried to get up from my
bedroom
brother where i got shot was numb the
half of my face was numb
where i got shot and i was like
what happened to you know like i was
really i'm really scared at the moment
and i was like man and people were
telling me like hey there's
something is protecting you and i
remember they they gave they
gave me a little holy debt and i started
like asking
like i didn't know brother i know i i
did not know better
and i would ask her like i want my
freedom like give me this give me that
and it would give to me in a sort of way
i remember that when i was going to
leave prison like
i asked i asked this particular gin
because at the end of the day they're
jins that they're just playing with
these these objects these objects
because the objects don't have any type
of power you know
um i asked him like give me a give me a
woman
i want a woman bro the most gorgeous
beautiful woman i can imagine
ended up in my life
look how crazy things are brother when i
left
when i left that world and when i lit
when i remember i used to carry a
a gold a gold uh gold necklace with
with a saint with that saint made out of
a human bone
you know they would get the human they
would get the bone and they would carve
it out
and they would they would take it to a a
priest and he would he would wash it he
would do his his
he would do his his things on you know
when i ripped it off and i threw it and
i ended up and i said
you know when i said you know what i'm
done with this life
that girl disappeared in my life bro
like everything was given to me because
i was because i was
because i was working for him because i
was doing what he wanted
now that i like i turn my back and i say
like
allah sent me that dream to show me that
there's two ways
that the first he's in control of
everything and he brought me he took me
out of this he took me out of the
streets
to put me to put me in prison because he
knew what the what the gins were leading
me to you know
and and that's why it's mind-blowing
brother because you know that
we're not on we're not on something that
is temporary you know
obviously it's it's it's a test and
we're going to get tested because
he tests who he loves you know um and
and
like you know how christians like
they'll be like just accept
jesus as your savior and all your
problems are going to get face you're
gonna
everything's gonna go well
nah man it's just that
it's gonna go well because it's not the
same with the slime you know whatever it
says that this is gonna be
is gonna be easy that's
i have no idea that's why the farther
you go the harder it gets
exactly and that's what that's what
makes this amazing because
when i when i decided to like strive
like i said i'm going to get up for a
fajr prayer
i'm going to get up and even if i don't
know what i'm saying like i'm gonna i'm
gonna practice it and i'm gonna recite
it and i'm gonna do my best to try to
to try to become a muslim obviously like
the type of life that i had lived
had i had a lot of bad habits you know
so i i wake up and i do my fajr prayer
um i lay down and i start and i i
started seeing
i started seeing a video of uh how
shaytan
comes into play and in this in this
world and
it's what he's what he's here for right
like i don't know where like i just got
like a really tired feeling on my body
i've never had experience with james bro
never ever and i've i'm telling you i've
been
working like there's more than 20 and 30
people dismembered you know
i've been to some really hard hardcore
like really hardcore
things that anybody like i've seen
people just look at that and like
they'll start
don't change color uh bad things happen
to them because they're not they're not
they're not able to support what they're
saying
because it's it's it's dark place bro
it's a very dark place where your mind
is no longer it's no longer in control
you're letting those
those those those genes control what
you're doing
um so when when when i started feeling
this like
this uh this tiredness i remember like i
was laying down like on the side of my i
was laying on the side looking at the
video like that
and i got something like everything i
lost all control over my body
and i felt how this this thing got on
top of me but like i felt like when you
when like when you're scrapping with
someone when you're when you're rolling
someone on
on a mat like that and when when i felt
the hand of the of of this gin grab my
grabbed my hand
i call this i call this gym like the the
devotees you know in spanish in english
that's
mr fingers because his fingers were so
long bro
like they would rap all around and like
i moved a little bit
and i and i felt like the second time i
thought how he went like this again and
grabbed my hand like that he hold
he he he grabbed me bro i never have
never been and i've never had this type
of experience
until that day he picks me up out of my
bed
and he turns me like upside down in the
middle of the room
a part of me was like freaking out right
like i've never had this type of
experience like i've never
seen these things and now why is it that
it's attacking you know
uh but i remember i i i i was trying to
speak and i couldn't say i couldn't
speak but inside of me i was saying
allah and just by saying that it dropped
me back on my bed
oh and i got up like really like my
heartbeat was like
what what just happened you know like i
remember
like you know when you're smiling like
they tell you ghost stories just to like
spook you
but you've never had an encounter with
this but with these type of things
and to be a a grown man coming out of
that type of life the cartels and
have an experience with the jail like
you'd be like what the
what's happening you know but instead of
like making me afraid
i was like if i was a true warrior and
when i was in the cartels i'm gonna be a
true warrior in islam
i'm ready to die first and i and that
god that making me that made me even
stronger you know it made my mind even
grow even
more because i knew that we're not
playing with games bro
whoever said we're sending this dean and
and is it this dean just because he
wants to
he wants to look good in front of other
people
he has no idea what he's getting
involved into and it's very dangerous a
very dangerous game you know it's a
very dangerous game so i started
learning that i had to get away from
people
because there was people around me that
were that were still committed
committing
sure and and i was accepting things i
wasn't accept i was supposed to accept
and i like i at the end i kind of i cut
all my friends
before before the call cut i was saying
that i went with this friend of mine
and and i uh i started blasting some
sewers on his
honest uh on his car you know he you
know those type of friends that really
like to have their music
uh really loud and they have their
system and it's like
[Music]
i did that just like so he could hear
what i was what i was listening to
because i would tell him like hey i'm a
muslim now
because he would always tell me like you
want a beer or do you want to smoke some
weed
i'm good like i'm trying to be i'm
trying to be a muslim so he would never
like he would he's like yeah
all right man so then when i got in this
car like i started blasting
some zeros talking for some service from
the crowd
and like he said something uh insulting
you know
and i remember and i told him
you know who you're talking to right
like i'll
i'll i'll steal this car from you know
i'll take you to a ditch and i'll leave
you there bro you know who i am i have
not played games if you insult my
religion
and he looked at me like dead seriously
he's like bro
you're my god we've known each other for
15 years like you're gonna do that to me
because he he's a he's a normal he's a
normal cannot you know he's not a karma
he's not that type of that type of
brother you know he's a brother that has
he's had everything
alhamdulillah god has blessed them and
he has everything you know
he's never got he's never gone in he's
never had a struggle
so when he saw me that i looked at him
and i told him that
i was like i'm serious bro like don't
test because i'm i'm struggling still
like i'm fighting with my old self
like and you know like when like in my
case
islam shows you to be very to have
control of your of
of of your nature of your human nature
your human nature
you know that's at the end of the day at
the end of the day that's that's the
game here
to control and suppress the nature that
we have
you know because our nature is going to
go against us every day
so i was like before like when i would
get disrespected
i would handle my business man and if i
had and if i had if i carried something
with me
i would give him i would give him what i
had you know um
now that i i miss i'm in this i'm in
islam like the other day i had an
encounter with
with a certain person i'm certain gang
banger um and i tried like when i go out
i work
long sleeves like i said i'm um i have
and and he he disrespected me in a sort
of way you know
and he tried to keep trying to get into
uh like a fist fight
i remember like i just grabbed them and
i i i flipped them over and i put them
on the ground my head
don't test me back cause i'm i'm not the
type of person that's just gonna beat
you up i'm gonna make sure you're
gonna get up like ever again like get
your bike and go
you know and i and i went and i was
walking back to my house and i'm saying
alhamdulillah
because i was i'm controlling myself and
i don't know it gets difficult but
you start suppressing all the all those
bad habits that you used to have
so my friends when they look at me
they're like is this for real man
are you for real or are you just playing
games this is real
this is real i'm not letting i'm not
letting go i'm not going to let go of
this
for no reason my brother bro you didn't
come this far to only come this far
in islam we call we call that the nufs
the desires
it's our it's our lesser self right
because we have our higher self which is
the one aligned with
with allah's deen and we have a lesser
self that's aligned with the dunya
and society creates an environment
pushing our lesser self pushing our
desires
everything's just that next dopamine hit
next dopamine next dopamine hit
so it's a far few between where there's
people like us
that really want to just disconnect from
dunya and just serve our creator and
please our creator
so bro alhamdulillah mashallah that that
you made it this far man
this was such an iman booster for me for
real bro
bro jessica like here bro may allah
bless you bro because
you're a force bro like everything you
just said
it's a force and i think this was the
best episode that we did so far bro
bro i think he froze
oh man i was like damn he's holding that
pose hard bro
yo man that's three for three bro yeah
man i love blessing man love listen
he said
what he was saying about like christians
and how christians are saying like oh
except jesus christ as your lord and
savior and all your problems will be
watched so we all your sins will be
washed away everything will be easy
it's like well shaytan sees that he's
like well
you know what they're kind of starting
to get on the path but
but they're not really there so i'm
gonna keep doing my thing
keep making them sin but i'm gonna make
it seem like it's easy for them and like
you said well like the moment we get
further and further to the truth
that's when we get to the point where
we're being tested the most
it's real tired bro
i agree bro because
hearing hearing this man's story bro
it you ever hear the this thing memento
mori
mm-hmm that uh the story remembers
everything
yeah remember your dad's bro like this
man was living that
every single day he still lives it it's
like bro we
we struggle to remember that we're gonna
die
this man had it right there in front of
his face every
single day bro
it's not a lot bro bro it's just moments
like this that
it just really shows me like wow we
started this podcast in the first place
bro
i know you got that feeling too bro it
was uh
like i'd say we were like a hour in
after he came back from the first dip
and uh my little bro was like with this
girl and they're like talking out here
so
i hear them and i hear my dad in the
kitchen but it's like bro
nothing inside of me wanted to be
anywhere else but right here
i was so present guys yeah bro
yeah i literally could feel shaytan bro
oh yeah yeah and like bro a lot of
people are gonna think i'm capping bro
but
i don't really do this for your
validation or anything but sometimes i
could hear stuff
like what's what's up it's like more
than that right so i felt a lot bro i
felt a lot of things pulling me to not
do this episode bro you follow me but
anyway
what i was going to get to on her is the
more that the viewers think
that we make these videos to spread
islam to them and like
just for them than them make content
right
it's not bro like i want everyone
watching this to understand
guys and girls that you don't know if
these
podcasts that we make has more of a
profound impact on us
than it does on you you don't know that
because i know i'm sure that bro me just
starting this podcast us starting this
podcast together
it's it's done a lot for my iman bro you
know
oh it's exactly what we started the
podcast for to share
the real conversations that we were
having mm-hmm
that's it that's it bro that's it and
may allah continue to make it easy for
us i mean and easy for zach brown has
these old gins that are just affecting
him bro we gotta get him to rookie roll
there's some like
gins around him that don't want to leave
him right dude what was that thing he
was saying that um
he legit and got like
fingered by the gin he didn't get
fingered
was like grabbing him he was calling him
fingers though
so i said fingered even though he didn't
actually you know
you know what i mean bro
guys if this video gets demonetized you
know why i got demonetized bro
bro it i highly doubt it's gonna get
demonetized because of
that specific thing that i just said
right there out of everything bro just
the title x cartel
you know damn well that's going to be
the first to use like oh no no no no we
can't monetize this here
i'll converse this time no stuck for a
lot get that i'll start
why would they say i mean you're right
all right so he was basically saying
like there was a gin that one day he was
uh sleeping and he was i think he was
waking up for fudger
and he was just on his phone just laying
on his side and he basically felt like
he couldn't get up because the gym was
on top of him
okay well i understood that i just want
to know if there was any like
pre-context no
but like how to get to that
just him just doing life bro just living
life trying to concentrate wow how did
how do you get to that like when he was
explaining that
what was he explaining before
i forgot what he said right before
fudger bro i think he was saying he was
uh
watching some youtube videos related to
something let's ask him he's easier
yeah yeah bro actually
no need to ask him we can just replay it
on the long time
allah
on you bro because i think there's a
couple there's a couple stuff just
around around the environment bro like
they're not they're persistent eh
and this is this is not a new brother
like i've i've seen
i see people that can help me with this
because i know that there's people that
are
working against this bro because they
are mad and they are mad because they
knew
[Music]
they knew the type of person i was bro
and that's why i'm not
i'm i don't feel bad crying when i'm
talking about this bro
we're here because there's a reason
we're here bro we are in need of men
men of action brother and that our men
are not going to be afraid to know
allah is the most great brother and i i
do need that i know because there's
because we have big plans bro you know
big plans to
to to to spread the deen in the presence
and alhamdulillah hopefully i i got in
contact with some brothers that are that
are muslims
down in close to those to those prisons
that are that are telling me hey we're
willing to help you if you get
if you get the the material we're going
to go into the prison
and they tell me like do you how do you
think you're going to be able to get us
into prison
but have connections everywhere i think
that's why they're
that's why that's why they're so mad bro
that's when they're so mad and they're
trying to they're trying to they're
trying to do their part but
they forget that we worship the most
high
let me ask you that when you say you
have plans you have all these
these goals that you want to do you and
your homies right there you want you
want to give some dollar you want to
spread the theme
what kind of actual like tangible things
do you have that you want to do like
what are some goals that you have in
mind
okay so before i before i
came well i was before i i gave my
testimony
i've been humble like i said you know
and i appreciate those people that that
stood
that stood with me when nobody stood and
that and that [ __ ] up
that fought and protected your life you
know you have to be very appreciative of
those people that
that are outputs and they put them they
allah has
for a reason you know and i've never
forgot about them you know like there's
a lot of people that they leave prison
and
they try to forget about whatever
happened in there i don't bro i remember
every single day i wake up alhamdulillah
i lost the most great because he took me
out of where nobody could have taken me
out but him
and and i and i i do my part by giving
them donating them
giving charity you know here drink
yourself something because i know what
it feels to have nothing inside of
prison
but i i i was planning already before
before i got it i got involved in this i
was planning already to
to start a business where i'm not going
to ask for charity what we're going to
do is we're going to
provide them with the job at the same
time they're going to provide us with a
product that we can sell
and that product that we're going to
sell we're going to we're going to the
profits are going to be for
getting the dollar material that we need
to get and being able to
to provide that value material down
there you know it has to be a
it has to be a a cycle here because i
understand like it's it's okay to give
to give charity
but alhamdulillah what if we could what
if we can provide these people with a
job
people that are in necessity letting
them know look it's because
it's because of this dean because people
that are worrying about you guys
and are looking for for a better future
for
for inmates and for mexico itself
because like i said
in order for us to change the society we
need to change the prison because the
patient the prison is corrupt
so that's my plan i i have
like i said i've communicated i have
communication with a lot of presents a
lot of because i've been
all over the place right and i've and
i've and i've basically told
told them this like i'm done with that
life but i'm starting this new journey
and i don't want i don't want you guys
thinking because i'm i'm i'm i'm in this
journey i'm in this team i'm gonna
forget about
what what the prison life was about you
know what what the
the the problems that you have in there
the the situations that you go into that
you go in there you know
maybe it was that maybe that's why i i
went into prison a lot how to
make me walk through that to understand
that that there's a greater purpose
maybe in in in all this
so we want we don't we don't want to
just like give them money you know
let them work for their money get it get
make
they make some beautiful purses bro like
for women they make some material that
is very high class material
and what we're trying to do is we're
trying to build a website where we can
sell these bags
in order to fund what we want to make
what we want to do that is
get dawa and get brothers with knowledge
that can give dawah inside of prison in
spanish
okay at the end they need they're gonna
need someone to like a lot of people are
gonna have questions you know
that only someone with knowledge can
answer like i said i don't
i i'm no one brother i don't know what
i'm still going through
i'm still having my word i still have my
words you know the fight but
i think this is this is the reason why
i'm here because i've always i've never
forgotten about them
so we can we can start this we can get
we can
we can get paid for the material we can
pay for the people that are going to go
down there
right nothing is for free bro you know
that you need money to eat
you need money to move you need money to
do everything you know
but it's not it's also not just it's not
just like hey just donate donate donate
no
we want to make this go and work both
ways you know so
so that they can understand that we're
helping it and we're we're creating a
job for them instead of president but
nobody
the government doesn't care about you in
there bro nobody cares about you
so what better what better what better
what better plan than to start this for
a good reason you know
not not not to to uh not to just ask
for something like i'm not that type of
person i've always known how to take
care of myself
and i used to be that type of person
when someone would have wanted to help
me like nah man i can work
but you know i've i've noticed that we
have to accept the help that that allah
gives you know a lot has planned for us
and sometimes we we
we say we say to what allah is trying to
give us we say no because i'm strong i'm
strong
i'm the love we have to be humble we
have to accept what's going on you know
so that that's basically the plan to get
that to get that started up
uh we were thinking like if this really
gets if this really gets uh
it's working we're gonna uh make sure
that we created
uh a recap center with people that can
that can give dollar to these to these
people because i've met a lot of people
that i've talked to and and at the end
of the day like i
i talk to a lot of people that are in
drug addiction um
like i tell them like before i was a
muslim i used to tell them like hey
like i would give them good advice you
know knowing that
that that the drug addiction you far
away from where you where you need to be
as a human being
um and it's a problem bro like most of
us
most i've seen i've seen a lot of people
just they just look for people that they
can that they can talk but they don't
look
they don't look at the people that are
rock bottom you know
that maybe a lot a lot would want us to
give to help them you know
help them get a get out of the hole but
you can't help them
i've seen a lot of that i've seen a lot
of people preachers that they go and
they preach them
but they can't help them because they
leave them by themselves at the end of
the day
they're surrounded by that environment
like this
it's going to be beautiful to have a
rehab center that is an islamic rehab
center you know
where we can help these people really
really obtain something out of it not
just get that that drug out of their
system you know
but actually educate these people with
with the dean that we're in
like i said this is not for me bro i've
had
all the money in the world i've done for
me this dunya has no value
you know what what i'm looking for is
what we should all be looking for that's
our afterlife you know
making sure that that that we're we're
secure in that you know
because this life like i said
with this notion of death that death can
come at any time
and i've seen it personally i've
personally seen people
one day they're here another day they're
god
god has been good with me just take care
of me i'm still here for a reason
like you were saying remember so those
are our plans right now
it's it's it's it's hard bro it's
basically it's hard because like
i'm here by myself i'm trying to involve
other brothers that could do something
that can actually help with this
like i said i'm a nobody man you know
although
all the things i knew how to do or just
do bad things you know for
for for this for these people and now
that i'm i'm here
i'm striving to get knowledge you know
he has good yes
some really big plans for us and i just
asked a lot to keep me humble
i mean i mean i mean guys if you made it
this far please when you're institute
tonight praying
when you're in uh when you're in doing
your salah today whenever you're doing
it just make some dua for the brother
zach that
he stays steadfast in his deen and then
he achieves all the milestones and goals
that he has for the dunya
before he leaves and goes to but that
being said bro do you have a paypal or
something
i don't have a paypal brother i will
explain to you in a personal message why
perfect you know so what ways do you
have of receiving money
um complicated but what we can do is
um i think like there's people that
obviously there's people that take care
of me
they can receive the money for me and
they'll make sure that the money gets
sick how about this guys if you made it
this far and you want to donate you want
to support the brother
you want to support it if you listen you
don't know
zack if somebody wants to support you
not to support you but maybe they need
that
that southern cup roll that that charity
that blessing from allah maybe they've
lived a life where they're just they're
just doing whatever they can just to
help people in need
and not people in need but help people
because they could use the money for a
better good that they're not using the
money for
for example like what am i gonna do with
money in the bank if there's someone
here trying to build a well trying to
build a school trying to build a masjid
right so for that reason if uh
if anyone made it this far bro and you
guys are you're thinking of supporting
the channel becoming a patreon don't
become a patreon bro
if you want to donate you want to
support something a great cause support
zach all right so we'll put a link in
the description down below we'll get in
touch with you after to figure out how
to set that up but
don't any guys help and and you know
zach deserves a man
and for the least all these people that
are in
the state that zach used to be living
the life that zach used to live
if not even farther down the road right
they could use this guidance they could
come to the
right path and it's the least that we
could do
brother imagine where i'm at being
knowing that i was
lost alhamdulillah allah's great
all right so i think uh with this tick
tock attention span generation
i think we should go on too long but
we'll definitely film another episode
with you so we'll get in touch with you
to schedule that in
i know you got any questions
uh have you all been hearing
it i i hear like someone going like
that white noise is that white noise or
what that's not white noise bro that's
the black noise from johanna bro
bro exactly bro
it's like you've seen this and this has
not happened
until right now but we serve the most
higher brother
we don't have nothing else to fear you
know
they they want to they want to cut the
project because they know that and
look at the most amazing thing brother
before i before i got into this this
platform of being able to share this
i was looking for people to help me uh
to help me start this business
uh to to invest you know and i would
always like i would do prayer
when i was doing my dues i would ask
allah help me because i want to help
these people
but i can't help them if i don't have
the ways to help them like
it's gonna it's gonna be hard
alhamdulillah since i
since i've been here and i've been able
to share my message a lot of people have
gone to that extent that they are asking
me what can we do to help you and i ask
and i and i just tell them at the moment
at the moment
like let's let me first see how things
are gonna how things should be done
because we need to do things right
it's not just uh doing things without
planning and without having any
intelligence you know so alhamdulillah
may allah bless us and may allah keep us
steadfast in this religion
and that's why i think that there's a
reason why we're here and that's why we
see all this
this background noise and we see all
this activity happening bro
because they want to they want to cut
this off but they ain't going to do it
keep trying bro keep trying all the gin
listening all the other because
we got what like a couple you know
thousand ten thousand fifty thousand i
don't know how many views it's gonna get
but
whatever number we have we don't know
what if it has more gin than human
beings watching this right so
to other gin i wanna give you a quick
shout out if you guys made it before
you keep trying bro keep trying to you
know stop the dawah
but to all the people that made it this
far guys smash the like button
share the video and stay tuned for part
two with brother zach inshallah
so and and just make sure that like with
everything that you're doing just keep
your intention pure bro
because like it it's at the end of the
day man like everything
that you're doing everything that we're
doing like alhamdulillah
is great but if we lose sight of what's
most important
then it's like we're saving everyone but
then we're
we're burning the bridge for ourselves
so just keep keep your intention pure
bro
alhamdulillah and that's what we it's
very important to be humble brother
that's why you when i see you guys this
video you guys are always very very
humble
alhamdulillah i know that that there's a
reason why we're talking
oh yeah because we need to be close like
these type of these type of muslims that
are very humbling that know what that we
can't lose sight on
on what we're doing and we can't lose we
can't lose
the the ground on our feet like
power corrupts but you know fame fame
crops
we've seen it with many people
bro there's um i might have five years
send me
like your email or something i'm gonna
send you this thing
that it says something that you just
said right there it just matches
perfectly i think
i'm not even gonna say much i'll just
let you keep it
and uh you'll see for yourself bro it's
it's it's and you know that's most
that's like that's what i i
i give thanks to my creator because like
i've been talking to
to my brother that god has given us an
intellect and an intelligence
to to be able to see what's going on
around us a lot of people
just want to hear what what what a lot
of people just want to get sweet
on you know they don't want to hear what
really what really has to burn us here
and have to take us closer to our
creator
keep us far away from the dunya that
that this dunya is going to pass we're
going to die
and we need we need to be closer to it
and alhamdulillah i'm glad that i'm
meeting you brothers
and i said i've been a big fan and i've
been i've been listening to a lot of
your conversations especially legit
because i've been having a lot of
situations with that but alhamdulillah
i'll be expecting that email bro to read
that i got you bro
i got you bro i'm gonna make do it for
you man
and um let's keep fighting this war bro
let's keep fighting one day at a time
the most important thing is just
constantly renewing our intentions left
right and center while we're doing it in
the first place
because the farther you go because i we
already know the harder it gets
and when it gets hard we lose sight of
what's really important while we're
doing things in the first place
this is a reminder to first and foremost
to myself and
anyone watching this if you got some
value in any way shape or form
just know it's from allah alone and uh
any mistakes anything bad was from us
all right salaam alaikum warahmatullahi
oh you you said him you said it best man
abundance is by far
a greater test than scarcity so like
imagine now imagine you had the
intention to help
but then your intention slowly began to
shift to make more money now you're
making more money
and then now you have this abundance
it's like okay allah is like all right
bro i know your intention was to help
i know your intentions shifted because
who knows our intention better than
allah
sometimes we don't even know our
intention [ __ ] so i was like all right
bro your intention was to help it
shifted towards the money
i'm gonna give you the money i'm gonna
let you help people but let's see what
happens now what are you gonna do with
this money
and then it's a big test to see if he's
either gonna give more money if he's
gonna give more
risk or if he's gonna strip it all away
[Music]
bro
[Music]
[Music]